[Music]
right ones I'm gonna be the best settle
down like your sisters he's stubborn and
selfish maybe he didn't want to lose
another one of his girls I wanna ride
with different trainers no do as I say
little girl I'm not your little girl
hi I'm Michelle Payne I'm a jockey I'm
available for track work I'll just be
outside if anyone needs me I think she
might be the manager she's got great
balance yes she you've got a group one
there's a reason they call it the most
dangerous sport on earth
[Music]
another injury to the head could be
fatal
when can I ride again
Oh woman jockeys they even come close to
winning the Melbourne Cup I will do
whatever it takes all comes down to
strength we're riding your horse baby
they're bloody ordeal not bad fall do
you think it's right it is about so much
more than that can I do this I know the
horse can go be a champion what you're
doing out to the race celebrating
they'll be kept 1965 my fingers id8
empire those 1974 let the others ride
the different trainers where I caught on
because you're not ready I'm ready dad
don't come off that thanks to you
that's a suit
I'm gonna find career in the country I
don't want to find career in the bloody
country I'm gonna ride great ones I want
to be the best
you're out of your mind get married good
traveling kids matters are you telling
your husband's to give up
the girls never gonna win the Melbourne
Cup tonight the only thing that matters
is the odds you give yourself
didn't want to see it settle down I'm
happy so okay that I found the one only
makes us
can I do this I know the horse can it's
gonna be a champion
you found it little girl
[Music]
[Applause]
you